hi I'm Jim Hanley Deutsch global
manufacturer a question came in from
Carolina Juarez Mexico she's asked about
what do you think our global economy
look like three five and ten years from
now or we could be rendered better ask
that question in two parts first over
the next three to five years I think
we're just going to see a little bit
more of the same the developing
economies we think are going to grow
really strongly they've got good
momentum we think those economies are
going to continue to keep that momentum
the developed economy so I'm primarily
talking about us and Western Europe we
do got a bump along with slow growth you
think they're going to grow but we think
that growth will be a little bit bumpy
you've also asked what can we do to make
it better that's a really good question
i think it gets to the 10-year view I
think the ten-year views are really
interesting one link in a ten-year view
some of those developing economies so
we're talking about China Singapore
Brazil even places like Vietnam and
Cambodia I think those economies are
really going to gain strength I think we
look out 10 years from now those
economies are going to be more developed
my that's really going to change the
landscape I think what we have to do to
make it better is continue to have the
right kind of policies to foster growth
there's a lot of great examples of some
great countries India and South Africa
come to mind they have policies really
designed to foster growth I think that's
what we have to see a bit more of